How can we simulate the motion of fluids and smoke?
If we had a block of plastic
in our computer program and we would add
the laws of physics that control the
motion of fluids it would immediately
start behaving like water.
In these simulations we're mostly
interested in the velocity and the
pressure of the fluid. How these quantities
exactly change in time. This we need
to compute in every point in space, which
would take an infinite amount of
resources. What we usually do is we try
to compute them, not everywhere, but in
many different places and we try to
guess these quantities between these
points. By this guessing a lot of
information is lost and it still takes a
lot of resources for a really detailed
simulation. It is not uncommon that one
has to wait for days to get only a few
seconds of video footage. And this is
where Wavelet Turbulence comes into play.
We know exactly what frequencies are
lost and where they are lost and this
technique enables us to synthesize this
information and add it back very
cheaply. This way one can get really
detailed simulations at a very
reasonable cost.
Here are some examples of smoke
simulations with, and without Wavelet
Turbulence. It really makes a great
difference. It is no accident that the
technique was a technical Oscar award.
Among many other systems it is
implemented in Blender so anyone can
give it a try.
Make sure to do so because it's lots of fun.
The paper and the supplementary video is
also available in the description box.
This is an amazing paper, easily one of
my favorites so if you know some math
make sure to take a look, and if you
don't, just enjoy the footage.
Thank you for watching and see you next time!